- In our school, we try to emphasize
different ways that students
can demonstrate their learning.
We really believe that when
students have some ownership over
how to show their learning,
it increases engagement and
their passion in what they're doing.
- At Kettle Moraine, we do things
a little bit differently than
the traditional high school.
We're all about personalizing
the learning plan for the kids
to give them voice and choice,
in whatever way or shape
they want to learn.
- Demonstrations of learning are the way
that a student will show you what it is
that they've accomplished over
the course of the semester.
A student may choose to
demonstrate their learning
by a discussion, by a presentation.
Students may choose to write
a paper, or create a video.
The possibilities for
demonstrations of learning
are endless.
- As a class, we kind
of move together as one,
but then we're all branching out,
doing our own things for
separate periods of time.
I really like this style of learning,
because I am able to showcase my talents,
and I don't really like
writing papers all that much.
I'd rather be hands-on, working
on what I want to work on,
how I want to work on it.
- Our pathways classes provide us
the structure and the opportunity
for competency-based work,
and that allows kids to
work at their own pace.
And then, ultimately, demonstrate
that mastery when they are ready.
- We're trying to get
rid of that concept of
you're in the chair for this many hours,
and that's what proves
that you know something.
Instead, it's once you
can prove your knowledge,
then we continue on the pathway.
- Each of our Pathways courses
has a set of competencies
that students have to
attain in order to earn
the credit for their course.
- In a web design class, we're looking at
three big competencies, which
are HTML, CSS, and Javascript.
Demonstrations of learning are essentially
any form of evidence that
the student wants to turn in
to prove their competency.
That gives the students a lot
of choice in what they do.
In my classroom, a lot of
students build actual projects.
So, they'll build a website,
or they'll write some software.
The Computer Science
showcase is an opportunity
for the kids to be assessed on
their competency.
The student's job is to
explain what they've created,
look at some of the hurdles
that they had to overcome,
and then they also focus in on
what those competencies were
and how they mastered them.
- I have a passion for computer science.
I'm going to be a computer engineer major
next year at college.
Having these options to choose a pathway
that I want to learn about,
really I think will
help me in the future.
- In art, the starting level
competencies are
the elements of art and
principles of design,
because that's what you're
gonna use to create all art,
no matter what.
If the students know they're focusing on
something like line and
color, it doesn't matter,
necessarily, the medium or the content,
it's really understanding those concepts.
And then once they understand them,
then they move to that next level.
Then the competencies get more difficult.
The critique is a
demonstration of learning.
They've got to introduce their work,
talk about their competencies,
and then get their
feedback from their peers.
Assessment for the competencies
in art is really portfolio-based.
It's the whole body of
work that shows value.
Students make a digital folder,
and they put all of the pieces in
that they think meets each competency,
and then we assess it.
Some of it's through critique,
and some of it's through
individual conferencing with students.
And then, once all the
competencies have a score,
they move on to the next level.
- Demonstrations of learning
are a really cool way
for a student to make a choice about
what it is that they want to learn,
and it allows for a lot of
creativity in how they show what they know.
I think the demonstration of learning
shows that passion,
and really helps with student engagement,
because they're really
interested in what they're doing
and to see that ownership over their
learning, that's really exciting.